[Music]
[Applause]
dodgers beat the reds last night and
they're currently the top team in the
national league west their pitching
coach is the former major league pitcher
and uh former all-star from the chicago
cubs mark pryor back on the program hey
mark how are you today
i'm doing well yourself i'm doing great
been a long time and uh congrats on the
gig as the dodgers pitching coach uh
give us an idea of what what is the role
on game day for the pitching coach
uh
yeah i mean i think basically
preparing
our starters making sure our starters
and our catcher um
you know that everybody's on the same
page from a game planning standpoint
uh i think that's probably the primary
role as far as the game preparing for
the game uh so it's a lot of you know
kind of back room uh preparation with
our advanced coaches and uh our in-field
outfield coaches on positioning and just
making sure we're all on the same page
on how we're gonna pitch guys
and attack them and then making sure
we're positioned accordingly hopefully
that so we can maybe steal some outs uh
whether it's shifting or not shifting
as things change and then
as well as just checking in with all our
other pitchers obviously with the
starters have bullpens in between
outings making sure that uh you know
we're prepared there getting ready for
the next start we go to atlanta this
weekend so
today we'll be getting kind of like
julio uh andrew heaney ready for those
those starts this weekend
um and then just kind of anything that
comes up on a daily basis which there's
a myriad of things that they come up
daily so uh
it's it's fun it's uh it's always
engaged no days no days the same and i
think that's what keeps it uh
you know keeps the adrenaline going
constantly
explain to me when a pitcher has it in
the bullpen but not on the mound or vice
versa
yeah i i don't know if i can explain
that i've uh i mean as a player
i learned quickly not to put too much
stock in how i was thrown in the bullpen
whether that was good or bad uh because
things for some reason change when you
get out there
and i think definitely as a coach i
always get asked like how was he and uh
i always just kind of shrug my shoulders
and say you know it was fine because
i've seen guys lights out in the bullpen
and then as soon as they get out there i
mean even last night tony was lights out
in the bullpen and he struggled to find
his command you know in those first
couple batters
uh and it cost him a homer a homer to
india but uh
i've seen kirsch you know one of the
best games i've seen him ever pitch was
in san diego a couple years ago and i
mean he couldn't find the plate in the
in the bullpen and he even joked about
it
uh on the way walk in he's like hey you
know did that scare you and i was like
no you look great
and you know he went out and
you know i think he struck out eight
nine guys and went six innings a plus
and uh it was just lights out against
obviously a very very good offensive
team with machado and tati so
you know it's a weird thing you know you
know sometimes it clicks sometimes it
takes until the fourth inning for it to
click too so
i i don't know it's got to be something
where you know you cross that line the
adrenaline gets picked up a little bit
and maybe you just kind of get off your
timing gets off a little bit and
and i think sometimes when you're bad in
the bullpen you just if you've been
around and you've done it long enough
you just kind of say screw it and you'll
be like you know i know how to pitch and
i'll remember once i get out there so
it's just kind of one of those things
that you don't really have an answer to
and you just you know as a pitching
coach you just cross your fingers and
you hope for the best sometimes that
these guys will figure it out because
they're really good at doing that
is it fair to look at today's starting
pictures or any picture as it almost
feels like everybody is headed towards
tommy john surgery or it's it's almost
like that badge of courage that you're
eventually if you if your job is to
throw as hard as you can for as long as
you can
is it avoidable
yeah i mean i i think it's avoidable i
mean it's it's definitely something
that's uh
you know it's part of our game it's part
of our industry and i don't think as an
industry we've been able to
you know tackle that that problem of how
to avoid it and you know we've
i think from
you know guys you're trying to protect
guys you're trying to limit some of
their pitches you know those guys go
down you push guys and you know say that
they're athletic and their their
delivery is great those guys go down and
then you got guys that you know
from scouts to evaluators to coaches you
say that's not going to work and they
never go down so
it's not a it's definitely not an exact
science it's not something that anybody
even if the success rate of tommy john's
surgeries and guys coming back is pretty
high it's not something you ever want to
do so
um but that you know i'm sure there's
some correlation to the to the velocity
i think you know the amount of
high
high leverage high intense throws that
these guys make on a daily basis uh to
generate the forces it's probably
you know long term probably not a great
thing but it's it's
what plays right now and this is how
the game's evolved and
you know it's
it's pretty amazing what these guys can
do physically uh unfortunately sometimes
there's a cost and that's you know your
elbow or your shoulder or something and
uh you just try to
try to minimize that i think you know
from where it was 20 years ago when i
first came in i think the industry's
grown leaps and bounds in a positive way
as far as training methods
uh you know the sports performance
industry and what the strength coaches
can do with guys to prepare them to put
their bodies in good positions so
i do think that we've come a long way in
trying to help prevent it
but i just don't think it's inevitable i
don't think it's avoidable with
everybody
knowing what you know now what would you
have done differently when you were with
the cubs
uh i don't know if i would have done
anything differently to be honest i mean
i i think i'm a product of of who i was
and what i did and the experiences that
i had so i don't think i would
definitely have changed anything but i'd
like to
you know played longer at a higher level
uh absolutely um you know what i've
maybe adjusted some of my training
regiments and maybe some of my you know
some of my delivery stuff you know arm
action knowing what i know now yeah i
probably would have made those
adjustments maybe sooner than after the
you know post injuries um but at the end
of the day like my experiences are kind
of how you know they've shaped who i am
today and i think they've
only helped me as a coach so i
definitely wouldn't have changed
anything and i loved
uh the moments that we had in chicago
but there's probably some things that
you know we just didn't know back then
uh as probably as far as the way the
body worked and the delivery worked and
how to train you know more as an
individual versus just kind of the
masses so i probably hopefully would
have been able to you know
you know do some things differently
uh to kind of maximize my body and make
it a little bit more efficient for the
way i worked um but as far as you know
my decisions to pitch to to go out there
every fifth day and even if i wasn't
feeling good i wouldn't have changed it
he's mark pryor he's the dodgers
pitching coach former uh baseball
pitcher certainly for the chicago cubs
uh i still go back to that carrie wood
day in april against the astros and i
know that you know they rank these
i think it was his sixth start of his
career
i don't know if there's another
dominating performance um and i know
they rank these
how would you quantify or describe
you know 20 strikeouts in a game as a
rookie against a really good astros
lineup
yeah a very very good team um
i mean it's
you know
it's got to be up there is at least a
top three if not you know one of the
best i think just when you when you
lump in all the variables to like you
said you know he has a rookie against
you know his fifth or sixth outing
against a really good offensive team
against you know some of those guys are
in the hall of fame or borderline hall
of famers
uh you know cold rainy kind of ugly day
um and just the stuff that i think you
go back and you watch the videos and you
know now we can quantify these
these things and these pitch movements
but
just to see the the movement on some of
those pitches the breaking balls that he
was throwing are were just ridiculous
and even now it you know when everybody
says the velocity and the movements
today are so much nastier i mean it
would be hard-pressed to
see some of the things that he was doing
with the baseball that you still don't
see necessarily on a daily basis he was
a frisbee he was he was throwing a
frisbee that day mark he was i i love
that description because if it's true
yeah no and it's so i think when you
when you put all the put all those
things together i mean it's got to be
one of the best performances of all time
and i'm sure there's performances on you
know in playoff games and stuff like
that that you know might rank
theoretically above them but when you're
just still looking at raw stuff and what
he did and how he made hitters look it's
definitely one of the top two or threes
you know maybe like a randy johnson
performance was probably in there
somewhere
um you know in his 20 strikeout games
uh
you know clemens back in the day when he
was just blowing guys by and those so
you know there's there's definitely some
dominant performances but i think just
the sheer awkward swings from some of
these really really good hitters uh it's
is pretty impressive you faced prime
barry bonds i got you you hit him one
time and the benches cleared
you remember that yeah yeah no i
remember that that was uh that was an
intriguing day for sure
well why why was it so intriguing
uh he's a uh he was a very uh
imposing figure and uh you know it's a
it was a game it was the third game of a
series and uh
you know it was
trying to think i think woody threw the
first game and might hit him on a couple
breaking balls and then i think barry
took uh one of our pitchers deep in the
middle game twice in a game and
um you know it was my intention was i
think i threw one of the three
change-ups i threw all year with the
pitch before and then we tried to go
back inside and it just got away from me
and you know obviously he didn't he
didn't appreciate it and i totally
understand that and but in the heat of
the moment you know i was young and and
probably a little brash at the time and
uh you know i'm sure i maybe said some
things that i
you know probably weren't most
respectful thing to somebody of his
stature so
uh unfortunately i had some older
veterans that you know grabbed me by the
by the caller and pulled me out of there
and said you know let's tone it down so
uh
no he was uh i mean he was a force for
sure and um you know fortunately i only
had to face him three or four times
because he wasn't in our division but uh
there wasn't a lot you could throw by
you know get by him or even make him
look silly it was it was ridiculous
during that stretch how would you sum up
the dodgers pitching staff
uh you know i i think we're doing well
you know injuries of uh like as the most
team's injuries have played a role in
where we're at right now but i really
like the way our guys come together and
stepped up
uh you know to phil come you know the
walker dealer void uh when clayton was
out you know we've had some guys and
tony gonzalon and tyler anderson and the
starting rotation and have done an
extremely good job of filling those
of those shoes uh tony's been pitching
extremely well all year has been really
consistent so that's been a nice
development and see his growth
uh i i think our bullpen you know is
always undervalued at times in the four
years that i've been here
um they come together as a group and and
really buy into
you know pitching as a group and
pitching as one as their own like kind
of entity versus individuals and and
that's really fun to watch those guys
they really come in they step into any
role in any situation
uh
and they get their outs and they do
their job and that's kind of how their
mindset is is to kind of pick each other
up and pass a baton so uh it's really
fun to watch our bullpen when it comes
together
at times they've really had to pick up
the slack during these injuries
in these last month we played a lot of
games in a lot of days
so they got taxed and there was never
you know in a complaint they wanted the
ball every single day and they really
want to go out and try to close games
out and so
from from that standpoint it it's been
really awesome to see and i think
ultimately that'll pay dividends at the
end of the year when with these games
hopefully we get some guys healthy
we get back to kind of you know maybe
not full force but somewhat of you know
the way you know our front office have
put this team together but
uh these big games that these guys are
pitching now i think pay dividends at
the end and uh you know
i think we're going to be a strong group
um
towards the end of this to hopefully
help our offense go out and win some
games and you know it's still a long way
to go but i've been really happy with
the way they've been pitching
attacking the strike zone and getting
out
good to talk to you again mark and uh
good luck the rest of the season
i appreciate it dan thanks that's mark
pryor dodgers pitching coach of course
he was one of those can't miss
he was a can't miss prospect
because we looked at his delivery i
remember baseball tonight would break
down his delivery man that that's the
kind of delivery you want that'll hold
up you know for a long career
but we also did that with steven
strasburg as well they were like he
can't miss
now strasbourg's had a better career
than mark did but when mark and kerry
wood were there and the cubs were
competing
and it was a fun place to be